hola
les voy a presentar unas palabras
favoritas y quiero que las vean que
piensen si saben qué significan cuándo
fue la última vez que la escucharon y si
de alguna manera aplica a su vida afecta
a su vida intensa a su vida
qué significa una pasada interés
qué significa la inflación
los bonos y las acciones
un fondo mutuo la hipoteca el valor neto
pasivos
riesgo
presupuesto interés compuesto flujo de
efectivo
inversión
ya lo pensaron
me voy a atrever a decir
que no hace falta muchísima educación
financiera
porque estoy segura que cuando estaban
leyendo estas palabras más de la mitad
no estaban claros de lo que significaba
y si la habían escuchado quizás no están
claros de si afecta a su vida y sigue
afectar como afecta a mi vida pero no
solamente no hace falta educación
financiera sino que además nos ponemos
la educación financiera o quien aquí el
sábado pasado dijo hoy no voy a ver
netflix hoy voy a tomar un curso de
finanzas personales
entonces hoy vamos a tener una dosis de
educación financiera y lo primero que
les quiero mostrar esto cómo se ve la
vida financiera de una persona que lleva
finanzas relativamente saludables y
vamos a leer esta gráfica de atrás para
adelante en el último círculo ustedes
ven la inversión y creo que todos
sabemos lo que es invertir pero hablamos
de invertir de multiplicar el dinero de
hacer más con lo que tenemos y es
también la manera en que progresamos en
la vida en un mundo ideal todos queremos
estar invirtiendo tal vez no ahorita
pero en un futuro todos nos vemos como
personas inversionistas en la realidad
muy pocas personas en el mundo o sea
cuando hablamos porcentualmente llegan a
invertir logran invertir y una de las
grandes razones por las que no logramos
invertir es porque no tenemos el paso
anterior que es ahorrar no logramos
ahorrar voy a detener aquí un poquito
porque tal vez no y usted está pensando
como me lo han dicho mil veces en las
redes sociales pero para que ahorrar en
eso es perder el dinero es hacerle la
vuelta al banco solamente hay que
directamente a invertir y me parece muy
bien
eso entra en contradicción con dos cosas
la primera es que no todas las metas que
tenemos son de inversión porque nos
damos por la vida solamente
multiplicando el dinero hay metas que
son de ahorro y que no tenés que ir a
invertir y la segunda y más importante
todavía es si yo no ahorro como invierto
y voy a vamos vamos a regresar un
poquito al pensamiento lógico matemático
a ver que estamos viendo antes y
entonces decía decía luis cuántos cuatro
por cinco
20 ok y cuánto es el 4%
[Música]
y cuánto es 3 por 5
y 3 por 100
y 0 por
10 por
50 por 100 y si yo tengo 0 peso ahorrado
por una tasa de interés del 100 por
ciento cuánto voy a reproducir
0 entonces no hay manera en que yo pueda
invertir sin haber ahorrado antes y eso
quiere decir entonces que para llegar a
mi cuarto paso de inversión
ok entiendo tengo que separar cierta
parte del dinero que yo gano todos los
meses para el ahorro perfecto el
problema es que la mayoría de las
personas no logramos ahorrar y una de
las razones por las que no logramos
ahorrar es porque la mayor parte de las
personas de américa latina están
seriamente endeudadas y la mayor parte
de esa deuda además es por deudas de
consumo no son deudas para invertir es
decir nos endeudamos para tener el
último celular el carro más bonito las
ropas nuevas que me quiero poner en
navidad el boleto barato que salió de
pronto en promoción en redes sociales
tomamos créditos con altas tasas de
interés para cumplir deseos que tenemos
en este momento y eso se conoce como una
gratificación instantánea perfecto
entonces si voy entendiendo esto quiere
decir que si yo quiero invertir tengo
que haber ahorrado algo antes pero si te
oí seriamente endeudado entonces quiere
decir que no puedo ahorrar ok entonces
lo que quiere decir es que tengo que
salir de deuda tenéis que salir de
deudas pero más importante que salir de
deudas tenéis que aprender a vivir una
vida libre de deudas que son dos cosas
diferentes si tengo diez años
dedicándome a la educación financiera y
he conocido cientos de casos de personas
parejas y familias que logran salir de
deuda una vez y a los meses están otra
vez endeudados con la tarjeta de crédito
y eso es como la persona que hace una
dieta baja de peso logró su meta de
bajar 10 libras
y un tiempecito después está de nuevo
comiendo las mismas comidas que comía
antes y obviamente subiendo el peso que
había
cómo salimos de deuda
salimos de deudas controlando los gastos
que hacemos hoy porque cada vez que yo
gasto hoy no tengo dinero para mañana y
eso me remite a la primera palabra que
ustedes ven ahí los hábitos
como estoy gastando yo mi dinero hoy
muchas veces pensamos que el dinero es
esto que está aquí afuera volando y
realmente el dinero está en cada una de
las partes de nuestra vida desde que
ustedes se levantan ustedes empiezan a
estar dinero porque se bañan y pagan el
agua y se ponen champú que compraron en
un momento y cocinan comida que en algún
momento también compraron si yo quiero
cambiar mi futuro financiero yo quiero
dar a invertir donde empezar por ver
cómo estoy utilizando mi dinero hoy
entonces esto nos enseña dos cosas este
ciclo de la vida financiera nos enseña
dos cosas la primera es que mi éxito
financiero futuro depende de lo que yo
hago hoy con mi dinero no mañana hoy
y la segunda es que cada meta que yo
tengo es en sí misma una meta financiera
todas las metas que tenemos son en sí
mismas metas financieras y ahorita que
ésta está por venir el nuevo año cuando
se fijan metas del nuevo año
y me puedes ir cuál es una de las metas
más típicas que nos fijamos
ahorrar ahora es una meta financiera en
sí misma
pasear ir al gimnasio
y del gimnasio
imagínate qué es una persona que en su
vida ha pisado el gimnasio puedo yo ir
de hoy para mañana el gimnasio que tengo
que hacer
tengo pero no este ni tengo quiere
escribirme y pagar tengo que comprar un
traje toda meta que yo tengo aunque no
lo parezca es en sí misma una meta
financiera que es lo que nos está
impidiendo lograr esas metas de ahorro
resulta que cuando yo tengo dinero en
mis manos yo siempre tengo que tomar una
decisión la mayoría de las veces esa
decisión es inconsciente y simplemente
agarramos el dinero y lo gastamos pero
de alguna manera estamos tomando una
decisión y esa decisión es o lo gasto ya
ahorita o lo ahorro y una parte súper
importante que se nos olvida es que
ahorrar también a gastar la única
diferencia es que en lugar de gastar
melo hoy
yo me lo voy a gastar mañana si yo tengo
500 córdobas ahorita en mis manos yo
tengo que tomar una decisión y esa
decisión puede ser y voy a pasear como
dijo alguien acá entonces pero ese viaje
a mí me va a costar
11.000 dólares si yo tengo 20 dólares
favorita o 15 dólares ahorita para que
voy a ahorrar que el señor meta son mil
no es nada pero si yo todos los viernes
estoy dejando de ahorrar esos 15 dólares
hubiera cumplido mi meta y así yo no sé
gastarme hoy esos 15 dólares o esos 500
córdobas es más rico yo puedo ir con eso
a una fritanga a un restaurante y me lo
gasto y lo disfruto y me lo disfruto muy
bien el asunto es que eso pertenece a
una gratificación instantánea una
gratificación instantánea es todo
aquello que me da placer ya ahorita
mismo en este instante no importa que
después no tenga para las cosas más
importantes o para todo aquello que yo
realmente quiero lograr una de las
preguntas que más frecuentemente me
llegan y me siguen llegando a lo largo
de los años es en qué invierto y no sé
nada la persona a veces ni siquiera
tiene una foto en el instagram o en el
facebook
y solamente en que invierto y uno si
tiene cinco años quince veinte si es si
tiene diez pesos cien mil no sé cuál es
la meta no sé absolutamente nada
entonces las finanzas personales son
personales la manera en que
administramos nuestro dinero también lo
ves y las decisiones que vamos a tomar
al invertir por supuesto que son
personales de acuerdo entonces la
respuesta a esta pregunta es depende en
qué invertir tu dinero pues depende
depende de muchas cosas que vamos a ver
ahorita no existe una sola fórmula
mágica y yo siempre digo cuando ustedes
les digan esta es lo esta es la
inversión del siglo 21 aquí es donde
tenés que meter tu dinero
esto no tiene un riesgo este es 100%
seguro eso tienes un retorno 100%
garantizado hay que huir de ahí lo más
rápido posible porque eso no existe
entonces cuáles serían los pasos que
tenemos que seguir realmente para hacer
una inversión adecuada a nosotros y
nosotros es quienes somos nosotros que
la tenemos cuál es la meta que tenemos
con cuánta plata contamos cuál es el
nivel de riesgo que podemos tomar cuando
necesito ese dinero de regreso y qué
pienso hacer con ese dinero pues cuando
vos con jugaste eso es y cómo puede
haber una sola respuesta a esa pregunta
tan importante entonces yo soy que
ustedes en la entrada le dieron un
cuadernito con un lapicero que espero
que no hayan votado y que todavía tengan
con ustedes porque vamos a hacer un
ejercicio yo les voy a decir a ustedes
cuáles son los cinco pasos que tienen
que seguir para tomar su mejor decisión
al invertir porque la mejor decisión no
viene ni de mí ni su mamá ni a su papá
la mejor decisión para saber qué
invertir va a venir de ustedes y hoy
puede ser una y mañana puede ser otra
porque porque sus condiciones pueden
haber cambiado entonces número uno yo
tengo que saber cuál es mi presente
financiero hoy cómo estoy estoy segura
que todos ustedes han escuchado del
fondo que es un toda fortaleza
oportunidad debilidad amenaza si están
estudiando alguna carrera relacionada a
business pues entonces siempre estamos
haciendo eso relacionado a las empresas
pero cuántas veces lo hemos hecho a
nivel personal y más allá de lo personal
cuántas veces lo hemos hecho en nuestra
relación con el dinero entonces su
primera tarea es esa auto conocerse en
su relación con el dinero cuáles son las
fortalezas que tienen cuáles son las
debilidades tienen cuáles son las
oportunidades que tienen es una amenaza
que tienen con respecto al dinero por
ejemplo yo podría decir una fortaleza
que yo tengo es que soy súper
disciplinada y en cuanto yo hago un
gasto agarro una aplicación o tengo mi
excel o tengo una libreta lo que sea y
yo anoto el gasto en ese momento de esa
manera no se me escapa esa puede ser una
fortaleza mía
también puedes tener debilidad es una
debilidad que yo tengo es que si yo paso
enfrente esto no aplica a mí pero si yo
paso en frente por ejemplo de una
heladería yo tengo que comprar un helado
entonces me va mucho dinero cada vez que
paso en frente de una heladería perfecto
cuáles podrían ser una oportunidad no
pues fíjate que yo he estado viendo que
este amigo tiene un negocio y necesita
dinero para para meterla a la inversión
y yo pues tengo algo y esa podría ser
una oportunidad para mí cuáles son las
amenazas que tengo a bueno pues he visto
que las condiciones ahorita del país hay
mucha incertidumbre hay mucha
vulnerabilidad y eso no podría terminar
afectando financieramente son ejemplos
número 2 voy a proyectar mis metas a
futuro que es lo que yo quiero y todos
tenemos que tener metas diferentes a
veces como que queremos de alguna manera
casi casi que copiar nos de las mismas
metas que todo el mundo tiene y no tiene
por qué ser así tu ser tu meta puede ser
a corto plazo quieres tener una maestría
tu meta puede ser a mediano plazo quiero
poner un negocio o tu meta puede ser a
largo plazo quiero tener un retiro digno
asegurado quiero viajar por las playas
de cancún y quiero jugar golf todos los
días mientras estoy retirado por ejemplo
número 3 y esto es el mayor regalo que
le pueda dejar ahorita aprender a
identificar tu perfil de riesgo
cualquier persona que se dedique a las
finanzas personales te va a decir que
antes de invertir tienes que saber tu
nivel de aversión al riesgo pero nadie
sabe decir cómo vas a conocer ese nivel
de aversión y esto es lo que sí quiero
que hagan ahorita yo le voy haciendo las
preguntas si ustedes se fijan en la
parte en esta parte de la tabla van a
ver que vamos de más tolerancia a menos
tolerancia entonces tres preguntas esto
está divido en dos partes la primera
parte es el riesgo de cuado para tus
finanzas personales y éstas pueden
cambiar en el tiempo pero ahorita
entonces qué tan lejana está tu meta esa
meta que vos querés lograr porque si vos
querés invertir quieres invertir con una
finalidad no es invertir por invertir no
es multiplicar por multiplicar entonces
esa meta vos la tenés a más de 15 años
por ejemplo me retiro a más de 15 años
es a mediano plazo entre 5 y 15 años o
es a corto plazo es ya de unos 5 años
por ejemplo quieres tener una maestría
en dos años encierren la respuesta
número dos ha estado ahorrando lo
suficiente para esta meta y tu respuesta
puede ser tengo más que suficiente sólo
tengo lo justo ahí apretadito o no no
tengo lo suficiente y finalmente contás
con otros recursos o sea además de este
dinero para esta meta que estás pensando
tenés un colchoncito de emergencia tiene
alguna otra cuenta de ahorros tenés algo
más si tengo muchos más activos solo
tengo lo justo o no no tengo
absolutamente nada más
una vez que evaluar el nivel de riesgo
que tus finanzas personales pueden tomar
vamos a elevar a evaluar el riesgo que
tu personalidad que es otra cosa puede
tomar igual hacemos de más tolerancia a
menos tolerancia la pregunta número uno
tanto sabes sobre inversión y puede ir
desde soy casi casi igual si no saben
quién es tan chica en temas de inversión
número dos se lo suficiente para al
menos considerarlo un número tres que es
inversión
la segunda pregunta si tienes una acción
si sos dueño de una acción en la bolsa
de valores que cae el 30% de un día para
otro qué haces con esta acción compro
más de esa misma acción pues me la quedo
ahí la retengo a ver qué pasa en el
futuro o no definitivamente la vendo por
que esto está perdiendo reales número 3
cuál es tu preocupación más grande con
tus inversiones
perderme de la ganancia o sea no ganar
más no alcanzar los objetivos de
inversión que tengo o perder todo mi
dinero cuando ustedes conjugan esas dos
variables van a tener una tabla como
ésta desde el riesgo alto en cada una
dzeko alto alto riesgo alto bajo bajo
alto o bajo bajo y eso les debería decir
el nivel de lo que realmente ustedes
pueden tomar
te voy a dar 10 segundos para que
encierren si están en bajo bajo bajo
alto alto alto alto bajo y una vez que
ustedes tienen eso entonces aunque hiela
ya conozco mi perfil de inversión ya
conozco al nivel de riego que puedo
tomar ahora en que invierto en mi dinero
ahora si podemos hablar de vehículos de
inversión
esta es una gráfica super sencilla que
muestra cómo se relaciona el riesgo y el
retorno porque toda inversión tiene un
riesgo no existe inversión siempre solo
volver a repetir no existe inversión sin
riesgo lo que sí hay son diferentes
niveles de riesgo para los diferentes
niveles tres diferentes niveles de
retornos por la inversión que vos puedas
tomar entonces vamos a ir de lo más
básico que es un certificado depósito
eso es lo más seguro que existe pasando
por la bolsa de valores acciones bonos
fondos mutuos bienes raíces
terminando en pequeños negocios y todo
lo que tiene que ver con el mundo de las
cripto monedas solamente quiero hacer
énfasis en algo la mayoría de los
nicaragüenses cuando piensan en invertir
pensar en montar un negocio y siempre lo
pensamos en chiquito voy a montar un
negocio voy a hacer esto bien pequeño y
pensamos que esa es la manera más segura
de tener nuestro dinero y lo que no nos
damos cuenta es que en realidad es un
riesgo alto pero que también la
posibilidad de retorno es sumamente alta
esto no lo digo para desanimar los y que
dejen de pensar en montar un negocio lo
digo para que sepan el nivel de riesgo
que van a tener y que aún así decidan
tomar esa decisión y finalmente siempre
tener suficiente dinero disponible para
aprovechar las oportunidades porque
nunca sabes cuándo van a ver esas
oportunidades y bueno tu futuro
financiero no va a ser exitoso si los
hábitos que tienes hoy les siguen dando
más prioridad a la gratificación
instantánea gracias
[Aplausos]
sus curvas